- Hey everybody, this is the
Ask GaryVee show and we--
- No, no, no, no, this
is my show, my show.
Roll the intro.
- [Gary] Yeah!
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody, and welcome to
Don't Put that in Your Mouth,
my name is Mark Cersosimo
and today we have a very special guest,
mister Gary Vaynerchuck,
thank you so much for being here, Gary.
- Thanks for having me.
- Really appreciate it.
- Fun fact real quick, I'm willing to put
anything in my mouth,
this is just super
importantly weird about me,
I understand that
everyone's gonna make jokes
but like, I eat everything,
including weird things like,
like I'm willing to eat non food things,
this has been like a big joke
amongst my friends for
a long time so like,
I have no idea how people do on this show
but this is a piece of cake.
- All right, well we don't have
any pieces of cake here today
but we do have some other stuff
Gary, if you don't mind giving the people,
the three people at home
who don't know who you are
a quick 10 second background of yourself.
- I'm an entrepreneur that's
caught a lot of attention
in the digital age by being someone
who a lot of people follow
on Twitter back in 2007,
YouTube lately, Instagram,
but I've built businesses,
first e-commerce website in America,
200 million dollar advertising agency,
early investor in Facebook,
Twitter, Uber, things like that,
make a lot of content for free,
five New York Times best selling books,
die hard Jets fan, that's me.
- And you built a wine
business from the ground up,
well, you took over your
family's wine business
and then it was on the ground
and you turned it into a skyscraper.
- Yeah, I mean, my dad
did an incredible job,
he came to America with
no language, no money,
and built a 3.8 million
dollar a year business
that I grew to a 60 million
dollar business quickly
which was the first way people
knew of me and then later,
so I left that business,
I built it for my family
so I didn't leave with any dollars
but made some good investments
in Facebook and Twitter
which gave me an opportunity
to start Vayner Media.
- Perfect, and now, this is not our
first collaboration together,
I don't know if you remember this, Gary,
we've made two videos together.
Back in 2013 we had this
little Vine video together.
Please buy Gary's book,
my life depends on it!
- Oh yes, dude, holy shit.
Forgot about that one.
- In front of an audience
at Barnes and Noble,
who I'm sure never forgot that moment.
All right, so today
we're going to be pairing
wine with three foods, and by that I mean
cat wine, wine made specifically for cats
with three different food
flavored candy canes.
- Let's go.
- Let's get it started.
So, do you prefer,
Gary, red or white wine?
- White.
- White wine for you.
- Cat wine.
- There you go.
So, today you'll be
drinking the Meowsling wine
and I'll be trying out the Purr-gundy.
- So this is literally made for cats?
- This is made for cats.
It is made with salmon oil, catnip,
and a few other ingredients.
- Wow, it smells like shit.
- Oh yeah, the sniffy sniff,
I'm not a big fan of that.
- I'm literally about to have cat wine,
this is wine made for cats
out of a plastic bottle,
or glass, Jesus, with some candy canes.
- What's up?
- Okay.
- So, let's give it a baseline taste here.
- Cheers, to good health.
- Cheers.
- That is atrocious.
- Doesn't really taste like much.
- No, it just tastes like
water and like sewer.
- I was expecting a little bit more salmon
from the salmon oil to pop
up but didn't get that.
- Sewer, it tastes like sewer.
- Maybe it is fortunate that
we didn't taste the salmon.
All right, so let's first try here,
we'll try pairing it with the
mac and cheese candy canes.
- That I'm excited about.
- Got one for you.
- Thank you so much.
- And one for myself, let's
just break into these things.
(crunching)
Wow, that really tastes like
mac and cheese, doesn't it?
- It's delicious.
- I kinda like it, yeah.
Not bad.
- It's really good.
- So how do you think this
goes with your cat wine?
- Cat wine enhances everything.
- It does, it really does.
That's got a lot of flavor.
I wasn't leaving, DRock, but thank you.
- [DRock] I don't know,
you've had a bad track record.
- Get outta here.
- You have.
- That's pretty good.
- Is this something like,
if you saw this on a shelf
would you reach for this
again, just by itself?
- Yeah, I would, I like this.
(crunching)
- There's a lot of people watching who
if they were in my position
would wanna ask you a billion questions
and I don't wanna have your time here
and not sort of take
advantage of your expertise.
- No problem.
- So I have four questions
for you as we go along here.
- Let's go ahead.
- First question, what
is the largest mammal--
- Are those oyster flavored?
- We'll get to that, Gary, settle down.
- Sorry, sir, what is the largest mammal?
- What is the largest mammal
you think you could knock
out with a single punch?
This question comes from Reddit.
Not for you specifically.
- I know the classic
nature of this question.
(crunching)
A pony.
- A pony?
(laughs)
Okay, I'm into it.
- You loved that answer.
- Pony it is, next,
we have some rotisserie
chicken candy canes.
- Wow.
- Let's jump right into these.
- Did you find these online?
- I did, yes.
- Makes sense.
How many episodes of this have you done?
- This is episode 31 of
Don't Put That in Your Mouth.
- And how many guests have you had?
- 31 guests.
- It's always a guest?
- Always a guest.
- This smells atrocious.
(crunching)
- Wow.
- Tastes exactly like it.
- It was surprisingly on point.
Remember Kenny Rodgers Roasters?
- I do.
- I think that's what the world's missing
is these fast casual chains
by country music artists.
What if Garth Brooks
opened up a restaurant,
what kind of restaurant would he open?
- Brad Paisley's Pumpkin Pies.
- Brad Paisley, if you're listening.
All right, how does this
pair with your wine?
- Terrible, it's really bad.
- It's kinda like a Thanksgiving
at my house, I don't know.
- This wine is so bad.
- Well it's got a little
bit of catnip in it so--
- It does?
- If you're feeling a little.
- I'm feeling a little bit excited.
- That's what I'm here for.
- Yeah, I'm attracted
to your coat right now.
(laughs)
- All right, so next question,
toilet paper, over or under?
On the roll?
- Over.
- That settles the debate
once and for all, folks.
I know all you out there are wondering
Gary's toilet paper
preference, there you go.
What do you think of Scott,
actually you know what.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- I don't wanna get into politics here.
- Get into politics.
- Scott toilet paper,
what's with people who
choose to use that?
Like, I understand it's cheap
but it's like sandpaper.
- Yeah, I'm weird on this.
So I don't even know if it's good or bad,
like I'm so not fancy when
it comes to toilet paper.
Like, I'll use a tissue.
Like, I don't even
understand the difference
between a piece of toilet paper and like.
- What about a leaf, would you use a leaf?
- I would use anything.
I would use my hand and
just wash it real fast
and pretend it didn't happen.
- Fair enough.
- You know, like if I'm being honest.
Like, I said this earlier about the food,
like I'm not, what is it
called when you're like, (gags)
gag to everything, what would that be,
what's the word of that?
- Yeah, what was that?
- Yeah, I'm the reverse of squeamish.
Nothing makes me squeamy.
- Well you're on the right show, sir.
- Yeah, I know, honestly I'm
very good like that, honestly.
Like I don't even wash my hands, globally.
Like that's just a macro statement.
- So like, you're in a public
place, a public restaurant--
- I go pee, don't wash my
hands, walk out, no problem.
I don't wash my hands often.
This is why I don't think I get sick.
- I have that same--
- You have the same thesis?
- I go on the subway, I tough everything,
and I don't wash my
hands, I never get sick.
- I also bite my, this is delicious.
- Oh no.
- This is delicious.
- Don't like this one.
Oh man.
(laughs)
- This is tough, I love it!
By the way, this would
really fuck with people.
'Cause I love oysters and
this tastes like oysters.
- It's not as bad as actual clams.
- You know what's funny,
oh, this is clams.
- They're called Clamdy Canes.
- Mhm, this is good.
- All right, how's this go with your wine?
- Ah, god, wine.
It's funny, it's basically
water yet still I don't like it.
- Gary, on an average day how many pigeons
do you think you could reasonably carry?
- Physically on me?
- Sure.
- That's the question, right,
like pigeons, how many?
- On an average day.
- At one time or over the the day?
- Over the whole day.
- How many pigeons can I
hold in a day, 17 seconds.
Like 190.
- 190, all right.
People, get your calculators
out, do that math.
You have any final
thoughts on the pairings
of these wines and candy canes?
I don't really know what to make of it.
I was expecting worse.
- The candy cane company
deserves a ton of credit
because the flavor profiles they're using
on their syrups or sugars
or whatever, you know,
colorings or whatever, on point,
tastes exactly like all three.
As far as the wine, the
cat wine was really bad.
I don't like it, I feel
uncomfortable about it.
My favorite was the clams,
that I thought were oysters.
- In the wine company's defense
this wasn't exactly made for us.
- Fair enough.
The mac and cheese would be number two,
the rotisserie chicken number three.
- You were really into those clams, huh?
- Yeah.
- Well, as a consolation prize
you can keep the rest of the box.
- Thank you, brother.
- Absolutely.
One last question for you, Gary.
If you could buy the Jets right now
with the one stipulation
that you had to wear Jordans
every single day for the rest
of your life would you do it?
- That's a great question, bro.
That it is a very well
executed question for me,
of somebody who understands me.
(dramatic music)
(clock ticking)
Not yet.
- Really?
- Really, I'd wait.
- Interesting.
- I think I can buy the Jets
without compromising that yet.
I think if you ask me
that question when I'm 63
and I don't feel like I'm
in striking distance, yes.
I just don't think I'd have to do it now.
- Fair enough.
- And I feel like,
on things that you don't wanna compromise
you try to wait until the last breath.
But I do think I would
compromise in the end,
I do, I think at 69, 74,
if I didn't see my ability to get there
and you were some weird fucking genie
with cat wine and, you know, clam canes,
and said bro, I can really do this,
you can own the Jets tomorrow
but you gotta wear Jordans,
I would do it.
- All right.
- But not at 43 years old
thinking I'm putting all
the pieces together properly
for the future.
- Fair enough.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- Thanks for having me, guys.
- Any final words that you wanna?
- Almost everybody who's gonna watch this
is unfortunately living their lives
based on somebody else's opinions
and that leads to
extraordinary unhappiness
and we need to start
making being a millionaire
not be a mission, but being
a happy person be a mission
and I really believe that
that's about to happen
and I wanna be one of the people
that drives that conversation
amongst the hundred
thousands of other people
that need to do it for
to actually become real.
But boy, do I wanna eliminate judgment.
Everybody here's judging
people, we judge so much,
and now with the way
modern technology works
it's so easy to judge at
scale with so little context
so, little less judgment
and a little more empathy.
(electronic music)